this beginner's course will help you
learn html and css by building a real
world project
madison connor teaches this course
she's an experienced front-end engineer
she is excellent at breaking down things
for beginners and explaining the
fundamentals of web development
hey everyone i'm madison and today we're
going to learn html and css by building
an order summary component
this course is for complete beginners if
you don't know any html or css then this
course is for you
this course is also for you if you do
know some html and css but you want to
cement your understanding of them by
building something
by the end of this course you will have
a professionally designed project that
you can use in your developer portfolio
before i got my dream job working as a
software developer which is what i do
now
i actually taught myself how to code
using free code camp so i'm really
excited to be here with you today
building this
let's just dive in and get started
the order summary component is a
challenge from front-end mentor
in case you aren't familiar with
front-end mentor we'll talk for a second
about what it is
if you're already pretty familiar with
front-end mentor you can just skip over
this section
front-end mentor is a place where you
can improve your coding skills by
building professionally designed
projects many of their projects are
completely free and today you won't be
paying anything as we build this
challenge
the main reason why i love front-end
mentor is that you can build coding
projects using professional designs
each challenge on the site comes with
starter files where you can see desktop
and mobile designs of the app you're
going to build
today we're going to build this order
summary component that we see here
the first thing you need to do is sign
up for a free account on front end
mentor and start this challenge again
you won't be paying anything in this
course if you haven't already go ahead
and go to frontendmentor.io
and sign up for your free account
next let's actually go to our project
here's our order summary component
before we talk about what an order
summary component is
i want to talk a little bit about how
websites work and how we use html and
css to build websites
let's talk a little bit more about how
websites work
right now you're likely using a web
browser so maybe you're using firefox or
chrome or safari
as an aside in this course i'm going to
use google chrome
and you can use whatever web browser
you'd like but i suggest you use google
chrome so you can follow along the
course as closely as possible
okay you're using your web browser and
your browser's job is to interpret html
and css files
into a website that can be displayed for
visitors
every website that you go on today has
html and css
today we'll write html and css
we'll put that html and css into files
and then the browser will interpret this
html and css and display our site to us
all websites have files
these are html css and javascript files
as well as other files like images that
you see on the web
all of these files will determine how
your website will look and act
another part of websites is the server
the server stores all the files on a
website
you can think of a server as just a
computer that's connected to the
internet and the server sends web files
to the browser
these are two core pieces of websites
the server and the browser the browser
can also be called the client
when you build websites you might be
called a web developer but there are
also these terms called frontend and
backend developer let's talk real
quickly about what these mean and how
they relate to the client and the server
backend developers focus on the side of
a website that users usually can't see
the server side
meanwhile front-end developers focus on
the visual elements of a website or app
that a user interacts with in other
words the client side
front-end developers work with html css
and javascript among other tools to
build the front-ends of websites
these are the fundamentals of how a
website works
let's talk a bit more about html
html is the foundation of all websites
html allows your websites to display
text images videos like anything you see
on websites today
front-end developers such as me use html
and css to make websites look good
we also use other things such as
javascript and other tools and
frameworks but that's a bit beyond the
scope of this course
html is the foundation of all websites
html allows your website to display text
images videos
anything you see on websites today
html alone might look ugly
but that's where css comes in
css styles your html
in other words css makes your web page
look nice
front-end developers like me use html
and css to make websites look good
now that we know some about how websites
work and how we use html and css to
build websites
let's go back and look at our order
summary component
your next question might be
what is an order summary component
think about anything you buy on the
internet
chances are you landed on a page
and you bought something
and then you saw an order summary
maybe you bought a movie on youtube or
you bought an online coding course from
udemy
or maybe you bought a subscription to
spotify
usually you will see an order summary
that tells you either like what you're
about to buy or
what you bought already so it's just a
summary of your order and it might show
how much money you're spending and
things like that
for everything you buy on the internet
it's likely there is a web developer
using html and css to build and style
that order summary page that you were on
now this project
is not just called an order summary it's
actually called an order summary
component
you might be wondering like what is a
component
a component can mean different things
for example
like a component in react can mean
something different than
a component in a different library or
framework
however for our purposes here today we
call this an order summary component
because it's creating a piece of
something
a component in other words is a building
block
when a user goes and they see this
component
they might see this data here that tells
them what plan they've bought
but this data could change depending on
the user
what doesn't change is this component
that will always render the same view
and the same html the data on the other
hand will be different
so this component could be used several
different times
if we look at this design
this kind of purple color in the
background this is the page so maybe
it's the web page that you're on after
you've purchased something and then this
looks like kind of a card and this is
our component itself here
an order summary component is absolutely
something that you might build when you
start working as a developer so you can
add this project to your portfolio by
the end of this course
if you want to have an extra challenge i
would say
pause this video now and try to build
the order summary component completely
on your own
if you get stuck you can just come back
to this video and see how i wrote my
code
if you do this route
your code might look different than mine
but that doesn't mean
there's anything wrong or bad about your
code
there are some best practices when it
comes to coding and there is some code
that is cleaner and more efficient than
other pieces of code but there's also
just different code writing styles so
just because your code looks different
than mine doesn't necessarily mean one
piece of code is better than the other
okay so let's look a little bit more at
this challenge let's just exit out of
here
now let's go down to this brief section
now here we can see our challenge is to
build this order summary card and get it
as close to looking like the design as
possible
this says our user should be able to see
interactive states
interactive states are for example
when you hover your mouse over a button
the button might light up or the button
might change color
we can also see here that we have this
amazing slot community if you get stuck
at any point in this tutorial you can
join this free spot group and get help
if you get stuck you can also look at my
completed solution
or you can look at all of the other
solutions for this challenge that have
been posted here on front-end mentor
okay let's scroll back up and we'll hit
visit challenge hub
now mine says i've already started the
challenge
if you haven't started the challenge yet
then you might see a slightly different
screen
but this view should look pretty similar
for you here
okay so next we want to hit download
starter files
next we see this step 2 which says
download design files
we are using a free membership so we
don't have access to the design file
but let me explain what this is if you
don't know
when you start working as a developer
you will often be given designs from
your designer at your company and these
will essentially be pictures of how the
application you are building is supposed
to look
figma and sketch are really commonly
used tools that you can use to see the
designs of the application that your
designer gave you
as a quick example we can go to the
sigma ui design tutorial on free code
camp
next we can scroll down and we can see
what the figma app looks like
okay so say you're working as a software
developer and the designer at your
company they gave you this design and
they said this is what this part of the
app looks like
you as the developer would go open up
your figma app and you can click on
things such as this new arrival text and
when you click on it you'll be able to
see
the exact font color used
you'll also be able to see other things
that will help you build the app and
help you make the app look as close to
design as possible
if we go back to our order summary
component challenge
we don't have our design files in figma
because we're using a free account
but that's actually okay because we're
essentially going to eyeball it
we're going to look at the pictures that
were given in this download starter
files kit
and we're going to kind of guess what
colors we'll use and this is going to
work out really well for us
i wanted to explain what figma was real
quick in case you weren't familiar with
design tools like sigma or sketch and i
also wanted to explain it because when i
was learning how to code i didn't know
about tools like figma and sketch and i
always wondered like how exactly does
the developer turn a design into code
okay so let's get to building we already
hit download starter files so let's open
these starter files in our text editor
the next thing i've done is i've opened
up my downloads folder and i found the
starter files folder
this says main three because i've
already downloaded this a few times so
yours might just say order summary
component main
let's actually grab this and we're going
to drag it down
into our vs code down here
when we dragged our download starter kit
folder into our text editor it opened up
our text editor as we can see here
okay so it might feel like a lot just
happened let's pause for a second
if you're not familiar with a text
editor yet a text editor is where you'll
write your code
if you think about writing
maybe when you go write a blog post you
use notion or maybe you use google
documents to write an essay for class
in google docs you write words
when you're writing code developers use
something called text editors
i use vs code which is pretty popular
but you can use any text editor that you
like
if you're looking right now at my text
editor you might see a bunch of things
and you just have no idea what they are
and that is totally okay
there are a lot of features inside of a
text editor and you don't need to know
all of them or even most of them right
now
let's expand
this i'm going to make my screen a bit
bigger
okay now we're in our starter files
let's briefly go over what our starter
files include
first we see this design folder
and here we simply have different
pictures of what our app or our
component will look like
and again if you work as a developer you
will usually be given designs by your
designer in a tool like figma or sketch
but for today we will be looking at
these pictures to reference as we build
our app
as a side note throughout the course i'm
going to call what we're building either
an app or a component
and sometimes i might just call this a
card because it kind of looks like a
card
just wanted to note that in case you get
confused later on when i'm saying card
or app or component i'm really just
referring to this project that we're
building
okay so we see that we have our order
summary component and then we also see
this thing called active states
now this is the view or the design of
what our card will look like when we're
in an active state in other words when
you hover over the card with your mouse
you might have this experience when
you're on websites and there is some
interactivity you go and you're about to
click a button you're hovering over the
button and maybe the button looks like
it bounces or it changes color or
something like that
now these are considered to be active
states
we also have mobile and desktop designs
and these designs tell us like what the
card should look like when you're on
your phone versus when you're on your
computer
for our purposes today we're just going
to focus on building the desktop view
if you like as an extra challenge when
you're finished with this course you can
work on building the mobile view that's
when you'll learn about things called
media queries
okay so moving on
we also have this folder of images and
this is just going to be all the images
that we use in our app
earlier i noted that web files are html
files but they can also be other files
such as images
so we'll be putting these into our app
now this is a bit beyond the scope of
the course but the next file we have is
this git ignore this is if you're using
git and github to commit your code and
then put it on github
if you're going to commit your code and
put it on github then this file just
says what files should github ignore
that is if you committed this whole
folder to github right now
then anything specified in this file
would not get committed or in other
words it would not get included next
let's go to this index.html file right
here
in this index.html file
we have a html setup as well as the
information we need to build our cart or
our app
and we actually could start coding in
this file but we're going to create a
new folder to build our app we're going
to create a new folder to build our app
because i want us to build this app
completely from scratch
next up we have a few readmes
now these are all really just telling us
about the project and how you can
complete this challenge
lastly we have our style guide and this
is going to show us the font colors and
the font family that we need for our
application
this is going to help us style our
project so that it looks as close to the
designs as possible
okay so like i said we're going to be
building our project completely from
scratch so we're going to leave this
folder here and we'll reference it later
next up we're going to open up our
terminal and start building our project
okay next i'll come over to my desktop
and as a side note i'm on a macbook pro
the next thing i'm going to do is come
down here and click on my terminal so
i'm going to click i term
okay so this is opened and then i'm
going to make it a little bit bigger so
you can see it
if you don't know what a terminal is yet
a terminal is just a tool you can use to
work with your computer
you can type commands into your terminal
terminals can seem really scary at first
but they're not too bad once you learn a
bit more about them
okay
next we're going to create a new
repository for our order summary
component
a repository is just a place where all
the code for this project will be stored
repository is also just another name for
a folder really
if you want to you can put your
repository on github
github is a place where developers can
share their code so other developers or
really whoever can see it and read it
again we won't go over github in this
course but i would definitely recommend
that you
put the code from this course onto
github and then you have that github
link in your developer portfolio
that way as a developer when you're
showing off your developer portfolio
others will be able to see the code that
you wrote
okay so next up we're going to use the
command mkdir
and this will create a new repository or
a new folder and we're going to name it
order summary component
this creates this new repository with
this name the next thing we want to do
is we want to open up this order summary
component repo that we just created
and we want to open up this project
inside of our text editor
so this project is just an empty folder
so far and we want to put files inside
of that folder so we can add code to
those files in other words we want to
build our website
so let's open up this order summary
folder inside of our text editor
we can do this by saying code
order summary component
and next we'll hit enter
and as you can see this opens our order
summary component folder inside of our
text editor
if you run this command that i just ran
and it's not working for you
then you can google openvs code from
terminal on mac and there should be
instructions on how to set that up
if you're using a different computer or
a different terminal or that's just not
working you can also manually open vs
code so you can go down here and click
open and then you can go to file open
and you can go find the repository that
you just created
okay next up let's expand this
okay i just took a quick break and now
i'm back and we're ready to start
creating our files
so here i'll right click and i'll hit
new file and i'll write out index.html
and i'll hit enter
this is where we'll be writing our html
earlier if you remember we talked about
how
websites are made up of web files such
as html files javascript files and css
files what we've done here is we've
created our first html file which is
really exciting
i think in this moment you might feel
like we're doing something really basic
and you want to get to the advanced
stuff
but right now we're really learning the
fundamentals and you will use these
fundamentals throughout your career as a
developer
you might be wondering like why did we
name this file index.html
index.html is a special name that we can
use and it will tell our browser that
this is the home page of our app
the index.html page is the default page
on a website if no other page is
specified
this index.html file will be the file
we'll view in our browser we're going to
hit this button which will close that
tab there so we have more space on our
screen
the next thing we're going to do is
we're going to write out an exclamation
point and then we're going to hit enter
i'm also going to hit command plus which
on my macbook will make the code a
little bit bigger
when we hit that exclamation point we
just created some boilerplate code using
emmett emit is a tool that's built right
into vs code
if you're using a different text editor
you can just look at our finished code
for the project that's linked below and
you can grab this html boilerplate
or you can pause the video and write out
what you see here on the screen
just make sure there aren't any typos
otherwise some part of your app might
not work
okay so we have this html boilerplate
but what is this code and what is it
doing when developers say boilerplate
code they mean pieces of code that are
included in lots of places without any
alteration
in other words code that won't change
and could be used for many projects
this html boilerplate is just some code
that provides a foundation for any
website we built let's look at a bit
more of this code
here we have this title tag this is an
html code tag that allows you to give
your web page a title
so we can switch this and we can say our
title is order summary component
and we can hit save
if you notice that when i hit save my
code jumped around a little bit and that
is because i have an auto formatter on
so every time i save my code gets
formatted
right now you probably don't have any
auto formatting on
but at some point you might be using it
so now we've added this title to our
site instead of document it now has the
title of order summary component
and instead of having to write out the
title tag ourself we just use that
exclamation point that automatically
added the title tag as well as these
other tags that we need we can also see
that we have this html tag right here or
in other words we see these words html
and then we have these odd brackets side
by side
so this is an html tag
this tag just tells the browser that
everything inside of this tag is html
we also see we have this meta tag
so utf-8 is a kind of unicode we need to
use encoding so we can translate the
letters we use into bytes that computers
use
this might be a little bit confusing and
you certainly won't need to know any
more about bytes in this course
the next thing you'll see here is
another meta tag with this viewport
value here
this might look super confusing at first
but essentially we need this for a
responsive site
a responsive site means a site that can
work on all devices like your iphone or
your tablet or your computer we want our
app to look good on all of our different
devices next we see we have this body
tag here
the body tag defines the document's body
the body element contains all the
contents of an html document such as
headings paragraphs images hyperlinks
tables lists and so on so in other words
inside of our body tag all of our html
will live here this is where it all goes
let's actually write out some html
we want to create our order summary
component but first let's just write a
hello world
we're going to use a bold tag and we're
going to say hello world
and we're going to hit save
again you'll see my auto formatter which
is just pushing this tag over here
kind of indenting the code and making it
look nice
okay so we'll talk more about what
exactly this is doing in a moment
but we want to next go and look at our
app in our browser
as a refresher we've created our html
file
inside of our order summary component
repo
we've added our boilerplate code this
basic html setup here
and then we've added this b tag with the
words hello world now we want to load
this in our browser
as briefly mentioned earlier websites
are usually made up of web files
web files are usually html files css
files and javascript files
let's go to our browser chrome
and let's open up this file
okay so i've opened up my browser and i
hit command o which opens this here and
now i can see that my repository is
already open here you might need to
search inside of here to find your repo
or in other words find your order
summary component folder that we created
next i'm going to click on index.html
and hit open
and now we've opened this up and we can
see our hello worlds i'm going to hit
command plus and make this much bigger
so i'm just zooming into the screen here
so here we can see that we've opened
this file up in our browser we can see
our app but this is just local to our
own computer right
this is not some url that is live on the
internet uh you won't be able to send
this to your friends as a link or
anything like that in other words we are
just viewing this index.html file
locally on your computer but it has not
been deployed to the internet
we could deploy our application to the
internet and that means we could go buy
a domain like
ordersummary.com and we could deploy our
app so that anyone who visited
ordersummary.com they could go to that
link and see our app but for now we just
have this locally on our own computer
we just wrote this html that says hello
world and i mentioned this thing called
a b tag
let's remove this b tag for just a
moment
so over here we're going to move this
away
and hit save
now back in our browser we can see that
this text hello world still looks
exactly the same
but if we go back to our app we can see
that the b tag is gone
the b tag is supposed to apply bold to
these words uh and so we removed the b
tag but we notice if we go back to our
browser go back to our app
etag looks like it's still there it
looks like it's still getting applied
and this is because we have not yet hit
refresh on our app
so we can hit command r or we can hit
this button right here which will
refresh our app
so we need to refresh our browser so
that it can see the new changes that
were made
every time we write new code or tweak
our code over in our text editor we need
to save that code and then come back to
the browser and hit refresh if we want
to see new changes that show up
so if i hit command r now we can see
that the bold tag is gone it seems silly
to be hitting refresh every time you
make a little change in your code and it
is kind of cumbersome and slow to hit
refresh every time
many developers use tools that make an
automatic refresh happen so that you
don't have to
manually refresh your page to see your
new code changes
however since we are basically just
getting started and we don't have any
fancy tools yet we're just going to be
manually refreshing our page
but if this drives you crazy don't worry
it drives a lot of developers crazy and
there's a lot of tools these days so
that you don't have to manually refresh
every time you write code that is
different or new
as i said once we have refreshed we can
see that the bold we had before is gone
now we just have this plain text that
says hello worlds
this text does look big but again that's
only because i've zoomed in my screen a
little bit if you zoom your screen back
out this text will be pretty small
here we just have this regular old text
of hello world it's just some content
here on the screen
but when we added the bold tag we told
our browser to display this text in bold
we can start to see a little bit of why
html is useful to us as developers
back in our app let's add a h1 tag and
we'll write our hello world inside of
there and we'll hit save
this h1 is an html heading tag html
heading tags are used to format headings
on your page in order of importance
an h1 tag is much like the title on a
cover of a book or the title on the
front of a newspaper
heading tags also have their own style
so let's go back to our browser and see
this style back in our browser if we hit
refresh we can see our text got much
bigger and more bold and this is the
default style that's applied to h1 tags
i've been talking a lot about html and
these things called tags let's go over
these html basics a bit more
html is short for hypertext markup
language
no one really remembers what this stands
for and it's really not that important
what is important to know is that html
isn't actually a programming language
html is absolutely a
valid language that programmers use
however it is not a programming language
it is actually a markup language
what's the difference then between a
markup language and a programming
language
programming languages like javascript
use logic to control things on the page
for example let's think about our
buttons that are in the order summary
component design
because we aren't using a programming
language today
nothing will happen when we click on our
button in the app that we're creating
however if we had added javascript to
this project
we could say okay if we click on the
button let's make something happen
let's add logic to control what happens
here maybe we'll move to a new view
or maybe when we click the button a
piece of text will pop up that says ok
all done
but because this project is only html
and css
our buttons in this application won't
have any interactivity to them
in other words they won't do anything
you might be wondering well if
programming languages like javascript
use logic to control things on web pages
then what does a markup language like
html actually do
html is the code that is used to
structure a web page and its content
html consists of a series of elements
which you use to wrap different parts of
the content on your web page we saw this
a moment ago when we created our hello
world
websites can have only html on them and
nothing else you can build a site with
just html and css however it will
probably be
a boring and ugly website because it
won't have any
interactivity
using javascript and the site will also
not look very pretty because it wouldn't
have any css and we'll go more into css
in just a bit
for now let's get a bit more into html
syntax so first we'll learn kind of the
concepts and ideas of html and then
we'll go use them as we're writing out
our application
let's go into html syntax more first
we'll go over the syntax and then we'll
take that syntax and we'll use what we
learned to build our application
when i say syntax what do i mean
the word syntax can seem kind of scary
when you first hear it
but syntax refers to the rules that
define the structure of a language
when you know the syntax of a language
you can use that language
first up let's talk about html elements
here this entire thing
is an html element
an html element is a basic unit of html
everything here
from the hello world to the weird
brackets you see to both of the h1s on
either side of the content
this is all part of the html element we
see here
now here when you see this odd looking
like greater than and less than this is
the html tag itself
this is the opening tag and this other
one over here is the closing tag
tags are a special kind of text that you
use to mark up your content on your web
pages
these tags will tell your browser to
display
whatever is inside of the tag in a
certain way
for every single html element there is
an opening tag and a closing tag if you
go back to our app and we go outside of
the closing tag and we just write hello
here and we hit save
then we refresh and we see that these
styles that the h1 are given here bigger
and more bold are not applied to this
hello and that's because this hello here
is outside of the closing tag of the h1
here
let's talk a bit more about html tags
so here we have the opening tag first
this opening tag states where the
element begins or starts to take effect
and then next we have the closing tag
over here
this is the same as the opening tag
except it includes this forward slash
before the element name
the closing tag tells us where our
element ends
in this case this closing tag tells us
where our h1 element ends
again this whole thing here is one html
element
our html element is made up of these
tags and it's also made up of the
content
the content is whatever is between the
opening tag and the closing tag
in this case hello world is our content
and again this whole thing with the
content and both the opening tag and the
closing tag this is all one html element
itself
we'll learn more about html as the
course goes on but let's go on to the
second topic that we'll be covering in
this course which is css
we're going to right click again and hit
new file and we'll say styles.css
before we start writing out our css
let's dive into some css basics
what is css anyways
css stands for cascading style sheets
it's a styling language that modifies
the appearance of the content of web
pages
css by itself can't do very much
the purpose of css is to style markup
language
in other words the purpose of css is to
style html elements and make them look
great
we can actually inject a bit of css
right into whatever html tag we went to
style
let's go do this
next we're going to add a style sheet
which will be our way of adding css to
our html and connecting the files so our
app knows that it'll use this css that
we're about to write
so we'll say link
rel
stylesheet rel is short for relationship
and then we'll say
[Music]
styles oops
styles.css
you see i have an extra quote here
just making typos all the time i'm going
to remove that and hit save
now we've connected our css to this
index.html file and we want to go to our
browser and test that this actually
worked
so let's remove this
so here
in our opening tag and in between these
two brackets
we can say style
uh
quotes
background color i'm using autocomplete
there your text editor might have an
autocomplete and then we're going to say
let's do aqua
and then we're going to hit save
if we go back to our browser and hit
refresh we see that this now has the
background color of aqua
next up what if we want to add another
h1 tag that says the hello world again
let's do that so we'll write h1
and here you might notice again that if
i just wrote up the first h1
i suddenly this second closing tag just
appears again that is an extension i
have that makes it a little easier and
faster for me to write html
so inside of here we'll say hello worlds
again
and hit save
what if we want the second hello world
again
the second html element here to have the
background color of aqua
well what we have to do is add this same
style attribute again
so i'm being lazy and i'm being a true
developer and i'm going to hit command c
in other words i copy this and then i'm
going to paste this here and hit save
now we've accomplished our goal of
having both of these h1 tags have the
background color of aqua
if we go back to our app and refresh we
can see that we have both of our html
elements and they both have the correct
background that we want them to have
now this is okay but it's going to get
tedious if we need to add this so many
times imagine if we have dozens of html
tags on our real website and we're going
to have to add this in several different
places all over
there is an easier way to do this
instead we're going to use css selectors
we'll be using css selectors all
throughout the rest of the course a core
piece of css syntax is the selector a
css selector is the first part of a css
rule it is a pattern to tell the browser
which html elements should be selected
to have the css property values inside
the rule applied to them a css selector
like this part on its own is the first
part of a css rule
so this entire thing is one css rule a
selector is a pattern of elements that
tells the browser which html elements
should be selected to have the css
property values inside the rule applied
to them
next we have these curly brackets that
you see here these curly brackets are
used to signify the start and the end of
the styles that will be applied to this
selector
everything in between these curly
brackets are styles that are applied to
the html elements that match this
selector inside of these brackets are
property value pairs
each property has a value
let's go over an example so here where
is the selector
the selector is this h1 element
here we are essentially saying
okay go select all the h1 elements and
make them all have a background color of
aqua back in our app we had to write
this code twice here and as developers
we really don't want to be writing the
same code over and over again if we can
help it
so instead we'll use our selector to
grab all h1 tags and set their
background color to aqua let's go back
to our app and we'll remove this style
attribute here
so we remove it and we remove this and
we hit save now let's go into our
styles.css
and we'll say exactly what we saw on the
screen a second ago we'll say h1
we'll do the curly brackets so this is
our selector
and then inside of our brackets these
are the css styles that we want applied
we'll use the property of background
color and we'll use the value of aqua
and we'll hit save
if we go back to our app and refresh we
see no difference which is exactly what
we want
the background color of both of these h1
elements is now aqua and we didn't have
to write the same code twice
okay so we've learned some html and css
basics and we're ready to jump into
building the rest of our project we will
learn more html and css on the way as we
go
one quick thing to note before we keep
going
let's briefly talk about how javascript
works with html and css
i mentioned javascript earlier and
javascript is
beyond the scope of this course it's
something that we won't be covering
but i want you to understand how
javascript works with html and css so
you can kind of understand how they
holistically work together
as a front end developer
you're going to use html and css to
build and style the content of your
website
you would also use javascript alongside
the html and csx
so these three languages html css and
javascript you will use them all the
time as a front-end developer
what's always helped me is to think of a
house analogy
think of your application like it's a
house
so the html is the building blocks of
your house uh the css is the styles of
that house
and javascript is the interactivity of
the house javascript is the moving parts
of the house
back in our app again we have two
different h1 elements here
and we've created this rule which says
for every h1 element give it the
background color of aqua
now if we go back over here
what if we do not want
this second h1 tag to have a background
color of aqua
what if we just want this to have a
regular color of black for example
the problem is we already wrote this css
rule that says
we want all h1s to have this background
color of aqua
every single h1 tag that we create on
this page
we'll get a background color of aqua
and we no longer want that
so instead we're going to use another
css selector that solves this problem
we want to say okay i want this h1 tag
in particular to have a background color
of aqua but i do not want this h1 tag to
have that color
we somehow need to differentiate these
two html elements
we need to somehow get this element
specifically uh target this element
specifically and make sure it has a
background color of aqua
but not this one
and to do this we're going to use a
class selector the class selector
selects elements with a specific class
attribute
back in our app inside of our h1 opening
tag we're going to create a space and
we're going to say class
and then inside of our quotes we're
going to say
aqua element
and we're going to hit save
i'm also going to just copy this
next we're going to go back to our css
and instead of this h1 we're going to
paste in that class name and we're going
to add a little dot right there and hit
save
now we are using a class selector
in here we gave our h1 tag a class with
the name of aqua element
and then we created this css rule for
this specific class if we save this and
go back to our application and hit
refresh we see that we did exactly what
we wanted this second h1 element no
longer has the background color of aqua
this is the power of class selectors and
again we'll use a bunch of different
selectors as the course goes on
let's start building the very first part
of our application
let's go back over here and we'll remove
this css rule
and then back over here we're going to
get rid of our hello world
next up we are going to write out our
first div
so we're going to say div
and then we're going to write out for
now we'll just write card and we'll hit
save
you might be wondering like what is a
div what is this
the div tag defines a division or a
section in an html document
the div tag is used as a container for
html elements
this div is going to be the container
for our order summary card we'll give
this a class of card so we'll say class
card and we'll hit save
actually we're going to make this
lowercase
you might be wondering why did i call
this card
well in my eyes this whole order summary
component seems like a card on a page
conceptually
if we go back to the design in front and
mentor dot io we can see that this is
the whole page and then within the page
is our component and we could also call
it a card it kind of looks like a card
on a page here
so the card kind of symbolizes the whole
order summary component on the page
the div that we just created with a
class of card
this div will be the entire component
that we see here
everything inside of this div will be
the image the text and all of the
buttons
in other words everything inside of this
div with the class of card will be
everything inside of our order summary
component
okay let's save this and then if we go
back and refresh we can see that so far
we just have this div with the class of
card and it just says card so far back
in our starter files i'm looking at the
design of the card or the design of the
component the first thing i'm going to
do is give this card a width so we can
see we have this whole page and there's
a certain width of this card so back in
our styles we're going to use the class
selectors and say dot
card
width this is the property and then the
value is going to be 450 pixels and
we'll hit save next up we need to give
this card the background color that it
needs it just needs a white background
so we can say background color white and
hit save again now so far it doesn't
look like much has changed we just have
this text of card
but again if we go to inspect and we
look at our developer tools
we can see that this card now has a
width of 450 pixels and a background
color of white you might be able to
notice the width more if we change this
so we can change this to orange for
example and here we can see that our
card only has the width of 450 pixels
and not anything more
the next thing we're going to do is grab
our css variables
first of all let's go back to our
starter files
and let's go back down to the style
guide
now that we've opened our style guide
we're going to take all of these and
just hit command c so we're going to
copy these
if you've never seen this hsl before
this is just one format for a certain
color
you might have seen a hex code in other
css examples and these are just
different ways of representing a certain
color in code
back in our application and back in
styles.css
we are going to push this down and we're
going to write out
roots and then brackets and we're going
to paste in our colors here
and we'll get rid of this code comment
if you're wondering what root means
this root is a place where we can
declare global css variables
so variables in other words that we can
use within all of our css
now we want to turn these into css
variables
to create a css variable we need to
write two dashes and then the name
so we're going to say
dash
put this into lowercase and then create
a dash here so this will be the name
together
and then we're going to do this for all
of the other ones
awesome and then we're going to hit save
we also need to make sure that we
remember our semicolons on each of these
okay so we can see we have a typo where
we need another dash here
next up let's test that these variables
work and then we'll see why they're
useful
so our card just needs a white
background but for now let's use a css
variable so we'll write out var
and then inside of here we need to add
the css variable that we want so we'll
say var dark blue and we have this nice
auto complete here so i'll just hit this
add the semicolon and hit save
then if we go back over here and we
refresh we see we have this background
color with the dark blue that we want
we don't actually want this background
color this isn't the color of our car
but we just wanted to demonstrate that
this css variable works let's remove
that and hit save
we'll also switch this back to just
plain white and hit save again you might
notice that this white right here we
didn't actually create the css variable
up here
it just comes with css by default so
it's kind of like a css
defaults variable whereas the specific
colors that we need in our app we
assigned those to css variables that we
created and we gave them custom names so
these names could really be anything
next up let's give our page on the
application a background color if you go
back to our starter files we can see we
have this beautiful like purplish or
blue background here and we see this
kind of squiggly wave right here
now this is actually a mix of two things
on the page it is a background image and
it is also a color
back in our app we want to take this
body tag and give it not only a
background image but also a color the
body tag is really the rest of the page
and our card or our component is sitting
inside of that body tag
the body element contains all the
contents of an html document
such as headings paragraphs hyperlinks
tables lists and so on
there can only be one body tag in an
html element
we are going to give this body tag first
of all a background image
let's first add the image that we need
if we go back to our designs like i said
we're actually using an image here to
create this kind of wave effect it's a
little bit hard to tell but that's what
we're doing
so let's go ahead and grab this image
we'll hit this button
and we'll go down here and we'll copy
this pattern background desktop so we'll
hit copy
next up we're going to create a another
folder inside of our order component
summary folder
so we'll say new folder and we'll write
out images and in here is where all of
our images will belong
we can create folders inside of our main
repo or inside of our main order summary
component folder to keep our files
really organized after clicking this
images folder we're going to hit command
v
next we'll close this again
and then back in our styles.css we're
going to write out
body
so our selector is the body tag in this
case and then our styles or our property
values are going to be in here
and we're going to write background
image
and then we're going to say url
images and we have this nice
autocomplete and we're going to grab the
pattern image that we want and we're
going to hit save
we also want to remove this and make
this white again and we're going to
again hit save
back in our app we hit refresh and we
also closed our dev tools and this looks
okay so far but we have to remember that
we're actually extremely zoomed in here
sometimes i forget about this so i am
actually zoomed in because as you're
watching this i want you to be able to
see the code on my screen really well
but zooming in can also sometimes make
your app look funky so let's go back to
a hundred percent i'm going to hit
command minus
right now we're at 300 and we're going
to go back down to 100
now we're back at 100 of the correct
kind of zoom size
and we can see the problem is that we
have this wave effect but
it keeps repeating on the screen like
it's much too small for the screen it
seems like and so it's just repeating
once twice and then three times down
here let's fix this
we can say background repeat
no repeat and we'll hit save
we don't want our background here to be
repeating
if we refresh now we see this is exactly
what we want our background is not
repeating and filling the space
the next problem is that we do want this
background image to be a little bit
bigger
so back in our app we use the background
size css property for this
the background size css property sets
the size of the elements background
image
for this particular use case we want the
value of cover
so we'll say background size
cover and we'll hit save
if we go back to our app and refresh
this is looking fantastic it's very
similar to our design
back to our design we can see that
we've already done this wave effect and
then the rest of the page has this
slightly different kind of purple gage
looks like the pale blue css variable
that we created earlier so we'll use
that back in our application i'm just
going to copy this because again i'm too
lazy to write it out
and then we're going to say
background color
and then we're going to save bar and
then paste in our css variable of pale
blue we'll add our semicolon and we'll
hit save or command s
if we refresh our app again we can now
see this is looking fantastic this is
exactly what we want
going on and looking at our design
figuring out like what should we build
next uh we can see that most of our text
inside of our order summary component or
in other words inside of our card
is this kind of light color
so let's go add that color to the div
that has the card class
so in here we'll say color
var
and it is desaturated blue
and we'll hit save
if we go back to our application
we're going to zoom back in so we're
going to hit command plus a few times
just to make this a bit bigger
we'll hit refresh and we see this has
changed to the color that we want
we can also see this change if we open
up our dev inspector tool so we can hit
inspect
and we can use this and select our div
with the class of card and we can see
that it has this color
if we toggle this it will go away and
toggle it back the color will be applied
again we used the color property because
the color property specifies the color
of the text
so if we wanted we could change this to
anything we could say pink and it would
show up here and of course if we refresh
this page again that pink is gone uh if
we refresh the page the original styles
that we coded up in our styles.css are
back and the pink will be gone so when
we fiddle with these colors down here
and we change these in the browser this
isn't actually changing anything in our
code base itself
it's just momentarily showing us like
what these changes would look like in
the browser so we can tweak things here
but it's not going to affect any of our
actual code in our app this dev
inspector can work amazing if you are
debugging because you can see which
styles actually got applied or not
for example back in our app let's say we
take away one of these dashes right so
maybe we just forgot the dash we made a
typo this happens all the time and then
if we go back to our app and we refresh
again
and we look down here we can see that
this color is no longer getting apply it
so our developer tools will actually
give us this little warning sign right
here
so you might come into the app and you
see okay the color is not there i wonder
why and you can inspect this and look
down here and see this warning
and this says invalid property value
this is kind of like an awesome clue
that css is giving you it's telling you
that there's something wrong with the
code
we can go back here and add this dash
again and then know that it's working
let's stop for a second and notice
something really interesting
so back over here in our index.html we
have this word cart
let's add another div nested inside of
it
and inside of this div we'll have the
content of i love coding and we'll hit
save
let's go back to our browser and we'll
refresh
next let's inspect this second div
and one thing we notice about this div
here is that
even though this div does not have the
classic card it actually has the soft
blue color right its text is this soft
blue
why is this
this div does not have a clasp that is
telling it to have this color of soft
blue and yet it is still this soft blue
color
we can find the answer by scrolling down
a bit and we see
that we are hovering over this div right
and then we see these words inherited
from div dot card
what happened here was that this child
div i love coding
it actually inherited its color from its
parent div that has the class of card
and our dev tools are actually telling
us that right here so we are basically
saying okay
any children inside of the div with the
class of card will also have the text
color of soft blue
think about this card div as being the
parent div
this div with the content of i love
coding this div is inside of the parent
div in other words the parent div has
this opening tag and the closing tag and
this div is between the opening and the
closing tag and so this is the child of
this parent div and here we're really
saying okay any children inside of this
div with the class of card are going to
have the text color of blue
think about this card as being the
parent div and the card inside of it is
the baby
and the baby inherited the way that it
looks from its parents
this inheritance is a fundamental piece
of css
css cascades
in other words this means that styles
cascade down or are inherited from
parent to child this can be really
tricky because sometimes you have a div
and you don't know where it's getting
its style or something on your page
looks really funky and you're like wait
i didn't make that div that size and so
it's inheriting some sort of style from
somewhere else
the next question you might ask is
what if i don't want my child div to
inherit its color from the parent dip
okay so if we went to rebel we can use
the class selector here so we can say
class and we'll just call this child for
now and we'll hit save
and then back in our styles we can say
dot childs and we can add another color
property here so we can say color and
we'll say red and we'll hit save
if we go back to our app and refresh we
can see that this child div now has the
color of red
so this child div has this color of red
and it's now overriding its inherited
color
if we scroll down a little bit we can
see that this is now slashed out because
we have a more specific color property
with a value set here and so this
inherited style will no longer
be applied here
this can be a bit confusing because if
you go back to our app and you say
okay we have this card div with this
color of desaturated blue and then we
have this div inside of the parent div
with the color of red you might
sometimes wonder like
okay which one wins here right like
which css rule actually gets applied is
it the blue one or is it the red one
and css answers this by saying the most
specific rule wins
and in this case the most specific rule
is the child div with the color of red
because this rule is more specific to
this div
this is called css specificity
i can never say css specificity right so
i'm going to try to say it as
infrequently as i possibly can
but css specificity is
the means by which the browsers decide
which css property values are the most
relevant to an element and therefore
will be applied
now this can seem complex so let's look
at a great cheat sheet for this
okay so this is a really fun little site
called css
specificity i again cannot really say
that without getting tongue tied
but here you can see when you are
applying styles to your divs like what
styles will win in other words what
styles will actually get applied in
order of importance
okay so now that we've learned about css
specificity let's move on and let's work
more on our order summary component
let's keep building
we're going to remove this child div
we're not really going to need it now
and we're going to go over here and
remove it here
back in our designs let's create our
title next this is our order summary
title
now back inside of our car div we're
going to actually remove this word cart
this was just kind of placeholder text
we don't need it anymore
next we're going to add an h2 element
and we're going to say order summary
and we'll hit save
next we want to add styles to this h2
tag
if we go back over here and we refresh
we can see it doesn't really have much
style on it yet
let's use a class selector
so we'll give this a class name of title
and we'll hit save
back over here we'll say dot title and
then we'll add our styles within here
first we'll say color so we want this
order summary text to have a color of
dark blue so we'll say bar
dark blue
next up we want to give this a font
weight of 900
and if you're wondering i got this font
weight from inside of our starter files
lastly we also want this to have a font
size of 32 pixels
and we'll hit save
again we're deciding how this style
looks from looking at the image that we
have in our starter files of the design
if we go back and hit refresh we can see
that this is looking a bit more similar
to the design
i am going to make this a tiny bit
smaller because it's a little bit bigger
than it's really necessary right now
that's better
the next thing that we want to do is add
this cool image that we see here back in
our starter files
so within our starter files we're going
to go and grab this image from the
images folder that they provided for us
this is the illustration hero so we're
just going to copy this
back in our application we're going to
go to our images folder and we're going
to hit paste
awesome so now we have this here now
when you see all of this
you might be thinking okay this doesn't
look like an image here
this is an svg which is just a different
kind of an image file
so it's kind of like a jpeg but there
are differences that we won't go into in
this course so now we can just close
this and we're actually going to close
this as well
and then lastly we'll close this so we
have more space and go back to our
index.html file
next up right above our h2 tag we're
going to use an image tag and this will
allow us to display our image
so we're going to say
image src
and then here we need to write out the
file path to our image so we'll say
images and then find it here
again we can use our awesome
autocomplete and say
illustrationhero.svg
and then we can use a closing tag and
hit save
one last thing we can do is add an alt
tag so we can say alt
hero image and hit save
an alt tag also known as an alt
attribute or an alt description it's an
html attribute applied to image times to
provide a text alternative next we can
go back and refresh and we can see that
our image is here and it's looking
awesome the great thing about this image
is that it's fitting perfectly
if we inspect this image it has a width
of 450 pixels which is exactly the width
of our car
but this width is actually not being
inherited from the car
so where are we getting this width from
like why does this image have a width of
450 pixels
if we go back to our app and we go look
at this svg
we see that there's actually a width
hard coded into this svg
now this is fine but imagine if we went
to use this same image in other places
in the application
for example what if we want to use this
image as
the background of another page in our
app
if we use this image as the background
in another page in our app then we would
not want this image to have the width of
450
but because this file is giving this
exact width of 450
that means that anywhere that we use the
image as many times as we use it it's
always going to have this width of 450
pixels this isn't great for when our app
scales right so if we do want to at some
point add another page in our app and
use this image again
then we'll be stuck with this hard-coded
width of 450 pixels and we don't want
that
let's go ahead and actually remove this
width
so we're going to remove this and hit
save
now if we ever use this image again
elsewhere it's not going to have this
hard-coded width of 450.
if we go back to our app and we refresh
we can see that this image no longer has
the width of 450.
this seems like a problem at first but
we're going to actually fix this let's
go back to our app and we're going to
close this for now we don't really need
it anymore
and we're going to give this image a
class
and we'll call it
hero image and we'll hit save
next in our styles we're going to go
down here and use the class selector so
we'll say hero image
and then we're going to use the property
of width and we're going to say 100 and
we'll hit save
with 100
means that we want to make this image
element have the width of its parent
element
whenever you see a width of 100 on a div
you'll know that that div is just going
to be the width of its parent
now if we go back to our app and hit
refresh we can see that our image tag
now has the width of 450 because that is
the width of its parent
we've added our order summary title and
we've also added our image
let's start adding some of the stuff
down here
okay the first thing we're going to do
is create a new div and we're going to
give it the class of container
and inside of this div is everything
inside of that white space that we saw
including this title
so here i'm going to hit option up arrow
and move this guy so he's nested inside
of this
container div right here
and then we're gonna hit save
let's go over to our styles.css and then
down here we'll say container and let's
give this some padding we can say 30
pixels and we can always go tweak this
if we want cool so if we refresh we can
see we have a bunch of padding
we just added some padding right now and
we talked a little bit about padding and
margin earlier but we haven't really
gone into
like what exactly are padding and margin
so let's dive into that right now
to talk about margin and padding we're
going to talk about one of the most
important concepts in css which is the
css box model
okay so the css box model
in css you can think of every element as
a box
so everything you see on a website
whether it's a footer or a menu bar
everything is a box if there is a parent
div and there are some children divs
inside of it
that parent div you can think of as a
box with certain properties and
all of the children divs inside of it or
different tags inside of it you can
think of as a box as well
and once you kind of understand this
you'll understand
how the html elements on your page are
working better and you'll be able to
write better css
okay so every box consists of four parts
you have the content
so the content is the content of the box
the content of the box is where things
like text and images appear
earlier we had that one div that just
said hello world and so for that box the
content was just the text of hello
worlds
um so you can have some text or video or
several images and all of that is the
content in a box and there can
definitely be a ton of different content
next you have padding so padding creates
space inside of an element
you also have border
every box can have a border and a border
goes around the padding and the content
a border can have like a texture and a
color and things like that
you also have margin so margin creates
extra space around an element so during
the pandemic we had that like
keep six feet apart roll so if you think
of yourself like as a box um you could
say you have you know six feet of margin
between you and other people it's space
between you and other elements
padding and margin are easy to confuse
and i used to confuse them all the time
but margin is when you want to have
space around the outside of your box so
you're pushing that box away from other
boxes on the page
and padding is when you want to have
more space inside of the box so space
between the content and the border
okay so this is called the css box model
and for every single element on your
page you can think about that element as
a box with these four properties
this is more of a visual representation
that you'll see in your dev tools and we
can see we have our content padding
border and margin now every html element
can have all of these things but it
doesn't have to have them
so in other words you could have padding
set at zero margin set at zero etc
okay so let's see this in action
and back in our app we're going to add a
paragraph tag
and we're going to put our text inside
of it and hit save
paragraph tags are used to define a
block of text as a paragraph
now we hit save we can refresh and then
see our new text showing up here
and then we're going to go back to our
inspector
okay so we're gonna hit this and then
we're going to click on our paragraph
tag here now let's write a little bit in
our css dev tools and again just to
remind you when we write in here in our
browser these are just showing us some
temporary styles but of course this
won't change any of our code
in our repo now let's say we want to
also add some padding to this paragraph
tag
so we can say padding and earlier we had
that 30 pixels so we can say 30 pixels
and if we look and see what happened
here
padding is in the green and so when we
said 30 pixels with just one value here
we gave padding to the top
the left the right and the bottom so
when there is just one value right here
with this property of padding that one
value gets applied to every single side
of the top the right the left the bottom
so what if we just wanted to give the
top of this div some padding and nothing
else one thing we could do is we could
say padding top and then if we look
again we can see that there's that green
right there only at the top of the div
so
padding is zero on the left and the
right and the bottom of the diff if we
wanted to give padding to just the
bottom of the div we could say padding
bottom
like that okay so say that you wanted to
have different values on the top the
left the right and the bottom so you
could say padding bottom
30 pixels
uh padding top
uh 25 pixels
padding right
10 uh padding left
5 pixels now
okay so you probably will never do this
because your padding right and your
padding left should generally but not
always have the same values but we can
see here that we just wrote four
separate lines of code
and instead we can use something called
css shorthands okay so you might not
always do this where you have
your padding right and your padding left
at different values
generally you'd want them to be the same
value generally but not always
but i want to illustrate a point here
which is what if you need different
values for
the bottom the top the right and the
left so you won't be able to use that
just you know padding where you put in
one value
and this goes everywhere top right left
and bottom so you'll have to use these
or you can use something else called css
shorthand
so if i uncheck all of these which means
they won't get applied
and then oh this isn't getting applied
because i have a typo here where i
didn't put
40 pixels you can see
so i'm going to
take this right here and then i'm going
to write in four properties right here
okay so instead of writing padding
bottom top right and left we can just
write out padding with four values you
might be wondering like how do i know um
which value is applied where so you can
always think about a clock so a clock
goes from the top to the right to the
bottom to the left so this first value
would be at the top then we head over to
the right just like a clock then we had
to the bottom and then finally to the
left so this is a css shorthand property
okay so we've learned about padding uh
next let's look at margin a bit
so again margin is used to create extra
space around the outside of an element
so we could say margin 50 pixels
and you can see this element now has
more space around the outside of it with
margin you can use all of the same
shorthand properties that we use with
padding we also have the content which
we've already gone over so the content
in this paragraph tag or in this box is
simply these words and lastly we have
border
we could give this a border we can say
border
um
one pixel solid orange
and there you can see a border showing
up
if we go back to applying padding we can
understand padding a little bit better
because by applying this padding
we are giving space around the inside of
the element so you can see that between
the border and the content there is more
space
okay so i've just refreshed the page
one thing that you'll notice here
is that there's actually a little bit of
extra space right here
i don't know if you can see that just in
the corner there
if we hover over our body tag we can see
that we have a margin of eight pixels
this is odd because you might be
thinking like i never remember writing
this this is actually what is called a
default style
so certain tags will come with default
styles like we said let's go and remove
this default style
back in our app we are actually going to
make a little space here and we're going
to say star
and we're going to say margin 0
oh margin 0 and padding of 0. and we're
going to hit save
here we're using the all selector so
this star looking thing this will select
all the elements on the page and we're
going to give them a margin of 0 and
padding we want to do this because we
don't want to have any default margin or
padding applied
if we refresh we can see that the space
we saw a second ago is now gone
the next thing we're gonna do is add box
sizing border box so we'll say box
sizing
border box
okay so what is border box and why are
we applying it to every single element
on our page
border box tells the browser to account
for any border and padding
in the values you specify for an
element's width and height
okay so first let's remove um box sizing
and we'll remove it so we can kind of
see the problem that it solves when we
add it back later
okay so here we have our card and has a
width of 450 pixels and if we hover over
here we can see
just below our card just below the
paragraph tag and the content we can see
that we have the width of 450 pixels
let's say for whatever reason we want to
add some padding right so we'll say
padding right of 50 pixels
and here we can see our card now has a
padding rate of 50 pixels
let's also notice what else changed if
we look over here we can see that we now
have a width of 500.
okay so our card even though down here
it says we have the width of 450 pixels
if we hover over our card div we can
clearly see that it now has the width of
500
and this is because the browser looked
at the width of the card of 450 pixels
and then it looked at the padding which
is creating more space inside of the
card and it said okay so we have the
width of 450 plus the padding rate of 50
pixels and so that equals a total width
of 500 pixels
here's the problem we set this card to
be a width of 450 pixels
but it's not actually that width anymore
and this is really confusing for a lot
of developers because we want our card
to have this width that we clearly
defined but then we're adding padding
and it's going to increase our card
width to 500
now what we can do is add box sizing
border box and this is going to tell the
browser that when determining the height
or the width of this div simply account
for the padding so we'll fit the padding
into the total size of the box
in this case we'll fit the padding into
the total width
in other words the browser will see this
padding right of 50 pixels and it will
fit that padding into the original width
of 450 pixels
let's go back to our app and we'll
uncomment this out and we'll hit save
then we need to come back here and hit
refresh
and then again we'll give some padding
right just here in the browser
hit save and we can see that we have our
padding but we can also see that our
width stayed at 450 pixels so our
padding was kind of shoved into this
total width
i'd say most front end devs add box
sizing border box to
all of their elements just like this
when they get started with a project
because
it's just more intuitive and it solves a
lot of problems where
our elements are much bigger than we
expected them to be
next up back in our designs we can see
that this text has some space between it
but if we look in our app this text has
almost no space between it
so we'll use line height for this which
can be used to set the distance between
text
back in our app we're going to give this
paragraph tag a class so we'll say class
order description
and we'll hit save then over in our
styles we're going to come down here and
we'll say order description
and we'll say line height and we'll try
out 25 pixels and we'll hit save again
we come back and refresh we can see that
there's now some space between this text
okay so let's keep going if we want we
can really build any part of this app
next
next up i think i'll add the border so
if we look at our design again we can
see that this design has a nice rounded
border
we'll go back to our card
and we'll give this a border radius of
20 pixels
back here if we refresh we can see we
have this nice rounded border
next up let's grab the font that we're
going to be using so let's come back
over here and let's look for our font
okay so here we see the font family
we're going to follow this link
okay so now we're going to add the font
weights that we want
so we want 500
we want
700 and 900.
awesome the next thing we're going to do
is hit import and we're going to copy
this link right here
okay so next up we're going to add this
import to the top of our app like so
i'm going to hit save
then inside of our body tag down here
we're going to say font family
red hat display
sans serif
we go back to our app and we refresh we
can see that we now have the font that
we want awesome
while we're here we can also give our
body a font size of 16 and i saw that
over in our starter files
if we refresh we can see we have more of
the size that we want keep in mind that
i am again zoomed in here so if we zoom
back out we'll start to see more of what
our app actually looks like but
i want you to be able to see this really
well while you're taking this tutorial
so i'm going to zoom back in
one bug that we'll see here is that our
borders got this really nice rounded
border on the bottom
but up here everything still looks like
there's absolutely no border radius
to fix this issue we'll use something
else we'll use the overflow css property
in this case we're going to use overflow
hidden
so when the content of an element is too
big and overflowing we can hide that
overflow
in our case here this image is
overflowing because
this image is inside of the car div but
its square edges are overflowing in
other words we have this car div that
has rounded borders
but the image is overflowing with its
square borders it's hiding the rounded
border of the card
so let's add overflow hidden to our card
div and this is essentially saying
okay when the content of the card div
overflows or in other words when it's
too big for the card then we are going
to hide that
okay so back here we're going to say
overflow hidden and we'll hit save
if we go back to our app and refresh we
can see that overflow hidden did its job
perfectly
okay so next up we want to add some
margin to each element inside of this
container
let's go back to where we created our
container styles
and we're going to say container
and then we're going to say margin 13
pixels
zero
okay so we're using this greater than
star which says all of the children
inside of this container they will all
get this margin with this value
when you have a margin property with two
values
this means that the first value is for
the top and bottom and the left and
right are at zero
we just gave each element a top and
bottom margin of 13 pixels and a left
and right value of zero
next up let's build these buttons that
we see here
okay so inside of our container div
and just below our paragraph tag we're
going to add our first button
the button html element it's an
interactive element and it can be
activated by a user and you can use it
to add
programmable actions such as like
opening a form or opening a new page
we won't go into that in this course but
those are some of the actions that you
can use a button tag for
since this course is all about html and
css our buttons won't have any
interactivity so nothing happens when we
click on our buttons they won't be very
exciting but we're going to make sure
that they're styled correctly to look
just like the design
okay so first off i'll write out button
and then i'll give it a class
the first one we'll call the proceed
button
and then inside i'll say proceed to
payment which is from the design and
i'll hit save
next up i'll essentially create an
identical button but this one will say
cancel order
like how it says on the design and we'll
give it a class of cancel button
alright if we go back to our app and
refresh we can see that
these buttons look like total garbage
these buttons also have a style already
which is kind of odd because we didn't
add any styles to these but like there's
already a background color of gray and
there's a border and again these are
default styles from the browser the
browser has a basic style sheet that
gives a default style
to certain elements
so we're going to override these styles
and make these buttons look how we want
okay so over in our styles we are going
to first focus on the proceed button so
we're going to say proceed button and
we'll give it a background color
of bright blue
and we're going to hit save
now let's go ahead and add everything we
need for this button so i'm going to go
a little bit faster i'm going to give
this some padding
a color or text color in other words of
white
and i'm going to give it a box shadow
let's give our button more of the styles
that it needs so we'll say width 100
border none we want to get rid of that
default style border
font weight of 700. cursor pointer
this means when you hover over the
button there will be a pointer
so it kind of indicates to the user that
you're going to click on something
next we're going to give it a font size
of 0.9
we're going to give it a border radius
so it's a bit rounded we'll go 12 pixels
if we go back and refresh this button is
looking so much better
you might have a few questions here like
for example why did we add a width of a
hundred percent we said width of a
hundred percent because if you remember
when you give an element a width of a
hundred percent then it's going to take
the width of its parent container
next up if we look at the designs we can
see that this button here is a certain
color and when you hover over this
button it changes color slightly it
almost looks like it's just a lighter or
more transparent version of the same
color
for this we're going to use the opacity
property so here we'll say proceed
button hover
and we'll give it an opacity of 0.8 and
we'll hit save the opacity property
specifies the opacity or the
transparency of an element
so if we refresh we can see once we
hover over this button now it has this
opacity applied next let's build the
cancel button over here we gave this
button the class of cancel button so
we're going to copy this and come back
to our styles and we'll say cancel
button and we're going to start to add
what we need first we'll give it this
background color of white
you can see it had this white color in
the design
then we want to give it a text color the
text color was desaturated blue
next we want to get rid of its border
that came in the default style so we'll
say border none
then we want to give it a margin top of
22 pixels
similarly to the proceed button we'll
give it a width of 100
next we'll give it a font weight of 700.
i got this from the designs again
next we'll give it a font size
0.9
next we'll add a border radius of 12
pixels
and finally we'll say cursor pointer
this button also has a hover state where
the text color changes slightly so for
that we'll say cancel button
hover and then we'll say color black
let's go ahead and hit save and then
we'll look at our second button
if we go back over here and refresh we
can see that our button is looking much
better much more similar to the design
and it has this hover when we hover over
cancel order
back in our application we can see that
for both of these buttons there are a
lot of similar styles applied for
example both of these buttons have the
css property of width with the same
value of 100 percent instead of
repeating ourselves by writing a lot of
the same styles twice we're going to
write them just once
so let's go up here and we'll say button
so this is selecting the button tag
because there are only two buttons in
this app we can use this tag to select
both of our buttons
so here we'll grab the styles that are
used on both the proceed button and on
the cancel button
so they both have a width of 100
they both have border none which is
getting rid of that default style
they both have a font weight of 700.
they both have a font size of 0.9
they also both have a border radius of
12 pixels and lastly the cursor pointer
great so now in our proceed button and
our cancel button we can go and remove
these styles
so we'll get rid of the width
border basically just all of these we
can start getting rid of them
you can do the same over here for our
cancel button so you can say border none
get rid of this
basically all of these and we can hit
save
if we go back here we can see that our
buttons are still looking great
for this app there are only two buttons
here and both of them need these styles
but you should be careful using this
button tag because this will select all
of the buttons on the page and give it
these styles so if you had other buttons
on this page you might not want to use
this button element here
next up if we go back to our app we can
see we have this purple box with a bunch
of stuff in it
let's get to building this by first
adding the html
first up back in our index.html let's
add a plan container that will hold
everything that we see in the purple box
this will go right below our paragraph
tag and above our buttons
so we'll create a div and we'll give it
a class of plan container
and then next let's add the image that
we see
we go back to our starter files and we
hit images we need this icon music so
we're going to copy this
back in our app we're going to paste
this into our images folder like so
back in our plan container div we're
going to say image src
and then we're going to say images icon
music
and we'll give it an alts of icon music
and save
if we go back to our designs we can see
that we have this middle section here
with annual plan and then it's telling
us the price
we will wrap a container div around
these two smaller divs so that we can
line them up where one is stacked on top
of another so let's add these
back in our plan container div we're
going to create a another container div
and we'll give it a class of plan
description
next up we're going to add the annual
plan and we'll use a strong tag for this
so we'll write annual plan
then next up we'll use a p tag
and we'll write out
59.99
slash year and we'll hit save
if we go back to our design we can see
that we also want to add this change
link right here
right below our plan description
container we're going to write an a tag
so we'll say a
and this is linking to nowhere for now
since we're just focusing on styles and
html
and then inside of it we'll write change
if we go back to our browser and refresh
we can see that we have the html that we
want i'm also going to zoom out a little
bit so we can see everything better
okay so we have the html that we want
but this isn't looking so good so let's
add some styles first let's work on the
plan container
back over here above our buttons we'll
say plan container and first we're going
to give it the correct font size of 16
pixels
then we're going to give it the
background color of that kind of light
purple that we saw
the app calls it blue but to me it looks
much more purple
so we'll say very pale blue and we'll
hit save
next we'll give this container some
padding so we'll give it 25 pixels of
padding and then finally we'll give it a
border radius because if you notice in
the design the borders are a little bit
rounded so we'll say border radius of 12
pixels
if we go back and refresh this is
looking a bit better however we need to
get these things all lined up
the next thing we'll do is add display
flex
the flex property sets the flexible
length on flexible items
the next thing we're going to do is say
flex direction of row
if we go back to our app and hit refresh
we can see this is looking much closer
to the design
lastly we want to add justify content
space between
the justify content property defines how
the browser distributes space between
and around content items space between
is a value that will distribute the
content evenly which is what we need
we also want to write out a line item
center
this will align our items to the center
if we go back to our app and hit refresh
again we can see things are looking much
better the justify content property with
the value of space between allowed us to
evenly space out these items how we want
them next up let's work on our a tag
if we go back to our design our a tag or
in other words the tag that has the
content of change inside of it looks a
little bit different than what we
currently have so let's add some styles
to fix that
so let's write out plan container
a
and we'll add some styles here first
we'll add the color so var bright blue
next up we'll add the font size which is
13 pixels
and we'll add the font weight of 700
and we'll hit save if we go back and
refresh we can see that our a tag is
looking much better
next up we can add the hover state so
when you hover over this change h i it
actually changes color
again we'll use opacity so we'll say
plan container
a hover
and we'll give it an opacity
of 0.8
we'll also give it a text decoration of
none
we wanted to add text decoration none
because when you hover over this link
there is actually no underline
underneath the link anymore
go back to our app and we refresh we can
see this is looking much better
next up we can see that our annual plan
text right here is very faint
but if we go back to the design it looks
much more bold let's give it the correct
color so we'll say plan container
strong
so we are selecting the strong tag and
we'll say color var dark blue and we'll
hit save
next up if we look at our app so far we
can see that everything inside of this
white space inside of this container we
created is not looking exactly like the
design we need to kind of center things
here and make them look a bit better
let's go add some styles to do this
back in our container div that we
created we're going to add a display
flex which we talked about earlier we're
going to give it a flex direction of
column
next we want to center the content so
we'll say justify content center
we'll also center the text on our page
so we'll say text align center as well
lastly we want to say font size of 18
pixels
if we go back and refresh this is
looking much better and much closer to
the design awesome
something else we'll notice is that in
the design this card is in the center of
the page but here it's just hanging out
off to the left so let's go back and fix
that
we'll go back to the styles for our card
and we'll say margin
50 pixels auto
now when you have just two values here
the 50 pixels is going to be for the top
and the bottom of the div and auto is
going to be for the left and the right
that is auto will be applied on the left
and the right of the div and the 50
pixels will be applied on the top and
the bottom
you might be wondering why are we using
auto right here
when we say margin auto for the left and
the right margins of an element
equal margin is given on either side of
that element and so this is how we can
center our card in the middle of the
page
if we refresh we can see that our card
is now centered
okay this is looking so close to the
design let's go back over the design and
see if there's anything that we're still
missing
if you go back to the design we can see
that there is a bit more space here
between the annual plan and the price
then we have in our current application
it also looks like the annual plan and
the price are a little bit closer to the
music icon than they are to the change
link so let's make these changes really
quick
let's add some styles to our plan
description which is the container for
the annual plan and the price
first we'll give a line height of 20
pixels
and the next we're going to give a
margin right of 75 pixels and we'll hit
save
if we go back to our app and refresh we
can see that this is looking much better
okay so we are all done we have
officially finished this course we have
learned html and css from scratch and
we've built our very first app we've
built an order summary component that
you can use on your developer portfolio
thank you so much for watching this
course